representing now the us
and here we go the game just started
the game has just started and it's the
four nights variation as you can see all
four nights coming out but it's the four
nights variation of the english opening
and uh after a set of exchanges both
sides are just going to develop very
nicely now this last bishop move is very
very trendy very fashionable
and it has caused sam sevian however to
think and we should mention a bit of
backstory to this game both players have
armenian roots i think both players born
in armenia um or at least level neroni
and represented armenia for a long time
sam sevian after being born in armenia
did move over to the us with his family
and uh sam the one thing i'm impressed
by him uh the maybe the most impressive
thing for uh for me at least is that he
plays correspondence chess which means
yeah which means you can use books you
can use computers you can do what you
want but you have a certain amount of
time and then you send your move to your
opponent then they have a maybe a few
days to think of their move and uh you
play maybe one move every day or two
and uh yeah he's one of the best players
in the world there as well and how long
will those games go on for them like
months years even they used to yeah
and sometimes by facts in those good old
days
and uh yeah you used to used to have
these world correspondence matches and
they were going for years wow
but now i guess would be
email yeah i think maybe up two weeks
maybe a month yeah um i think as well
for example on chess 24 you can play a
move and then
you know you just leave it there and
then
you your opponent will come back a
couple of days later they'll play the
move you just see it being updated you
get a notification and
yeah i don't have the patience for it
but that's why i'm so impressed by sam
sevian and
that that also shows that he works well
with books he knows how to work well
with
computers because imagine all of your
opponents have access to computers you
all have access to the best moves you
all see that everything should be a draw
but you find ways to trick your opponent
you find small advantages here and there
and how is it possible to win if both
sides can use computers there would
never be blunders there will never be
big blunders but uh that's where i think
you have to really understand how to use
computers and also you use the human
touch you look for positions where you
can dom it you might see that computer
might say oh it's roughly level but you
dominate your opponent's army and long
long term you win
um using that type of domination and
a draw it's a very common result you
should say correspondence chess nowadays
but
um yeah it's definitely an art form how
cool
and well sam savion greater
correspondence chess but he's also great
at online rapid chess we see him with 14
points and we didn't have a chance to
look at results from previous round
round six so we're going to take a look
at results and standings now because
both sam savion and levon aronian they
are coming from wins we had a lot of
decided games in the previous round uh
jeffrey chong did get a walk over win
against team raj above sam as we
mentioned a win against fellow american
hans niemann lebonroni and he beat
aryanthari and a win for radus
lavoitacek against juwen jun a win for
the youngest player in the tournament
arjun erigaisi against sam shanklin and
wei he won his game against chakri and
mondero so now let's take a look at the
standings because look at that
we still have those two young americans
on top of the table
jeffrey with 15 out of 18 possible
points
sam with uh 14 impressive and um
eric icey only 18 years old he is in
third place young christoph duda 24
in fourth place wei yi i think he's only
23. i mean the youngsters you have
shakti out of mohammed yarov you know
the only one sort of uh
uh protecting the honor of the older
yeah
he isn't he's the only one and
is climbing on the other half you only
have arientari actually
you see he's there
with the oldies but i mean the oldies
they're not they're not really uh very
old they're not old they're just older
yes exactly the very
young group of players on top of the
table yeah how cool the top five they're
all between 18 and what 23 24. yeah
yeah scary how good these guys are at
such a young age and sam sevilla i wish
i mentioned he's on a roll i think he's
won three games in a row now yesterday
beating jeffrey zhong in the last game
and then winning the first two games
today
so uh he definitely won't be scared of
his
uh now compatriot levon iranian yeah
and uh well let's dive into the game
what are we looking at here they played
very fast first 13 moves yeah we haven't
commented too much on the moves because
most of it's been seen before at least
until the last couple of moves i'd seen
everything
everything in analysis and in games over
the board but this last couple of moves
we should mention the pawn structure as
well it's slightly imbalanced same
pieces same number of pawns but white
does have one extra central pawn right
now white structure is very compact just
like we saw in gary's game in the last
in the last round white's pawns will
defend each other they're very modestly
placed white's minor pieces also very
modestly placed at the moment but they
are full of potential especially i'm
looking at that bishop in front of the
white king it's on a nice long diagonal
white's knight has several squares it
might want to jump into
white's rook in the corner might want to
swing across to the c file where it will
have a few targets it'll be on a
semi-open file there so white's position
has a lot of potential meanwhile black
has some work to do because black has a
bit more space black's last move pushing
a pawn gaining space on the queen side
looks great black has a nice pawn in the
middle of the board as well but as we
know great space with great space comes
great responsibility and black will need
to cover all of those pawns need to
cover all of the squares that he's taken
control of and
traditionally i i quite like these
positions for white especially now there
has been a trade earlier of one set of
nights which means despite white being a
bit cramped it doesn't matter so much
the rest of his pieces the remaining
pieces for white can jump uh to better
squares black does have a few more holes
and also black's queen it's kind of
leading from the front at the moment and
that is maybe not an ideal situation
queens normally they want to be bringing
up the rear of your army they want to be
supporting and only later in the game do
they want to break forward and uh be the
dominant attacking piece so black's
queen it's been kicked about a couple of
times already i'm scared that levon
ironian will need to move that queen a
couple more times in order to put it on
a good square later so um just a few
factors there at the moment sam savian i
just have a feeling he's deciding where
to jump forward
uh with the white knight he has maybe
three very tempting squares right now
also the white queen might want to
improve the white rook in the corner you
have a whole bunch of pawns to push and
this type of position it appeals to
flexible players who just want to kind
of freestyle what kind of plans to come
up with
but
there's a lot of choice and that's
maybe a downside in the end wow he
pushes this pawn two squares forward
this is committal it leaves a hole it
leaves an outpost on the square next to
it but uh it does stop black from
advancing so pros and cons with this one
maybe we can just show
the drawback between uh behind sam
cevian's last move he's just completely
given away control over the b4 square
which is now an outpost for black's
bishop or for the black knight
but at the same time it's often
important to stop your opponent
advancing for example if he pushed this
pawn one square black continue advancing
and black has completely clamped down on
this side of the board this pawn is
fantastic supported by the black rook
and white will never be able to use
these squares again
for example now after pushing this pawn
forward yes he's given away one square
but he wins the square next to that now
this knight can never be kicked away by
a black pawn
yeah ups and downs it's all about these
small kind of strategic
factors right now it's not about tactics
it's not about an attack white would
love to place a knight on this square
and what is black doing in the meantime
that's the question for example black's
queen might want to move out the way
in order to get this bishop out into the
action maybe the queen will move and
this bishop might develop
ivanka any preferences here whose side
would you pick in the current position
white white white because uh i mean you
kind of called it there i just like the
the value of the light squared bishop um
it's on a fantastic diagonal and also
you know white has also relatively
straightforward plan of just putting a
rook on a half open line and
exerting some pressure you know white's
night like you mentioned so many
flexible options meanwhile the only plan
that i could see for black
was to
simply
go for
checkmate so to speak you know move the
queen to a
the h5 square and then follow that up
with bishop um
bishop h3 uh topping oh look at that you
spotted the future
you really should buy a lottery ticket
if anker you always get to play as much
i always worry for the players when they
suggest when they play my moves um yeah
i mean this was the only thing that i
could see actually yeah to trade off
white's best minor piece this is the
best minor piece for sure it keeps the
white king safe it's actually the only
defender of white's king
and of course it just has so much
influence long term on this diagonal so
maybe attacking the white king but more
importantly for example if white just
improves a piece black is just going to
eliminate the best piece in white's camp
and once you trade this off now
protected by the black queen then black
has decent chances it's all about
whether white can stop this idea of the
bishop coming forward one thing you
definitely don't want to do as white is
get greedy here you can get greedy and
win a pawn by playing bishop takes
knight ruining the black pawn stretch
actually
and uh you can win this pawn on the a5
square but suddenly look how
bereft of defenders the white king is
the white king has no protection around
it black bishop is going to come into
the attack uh i could definitely imagine
the black queen somehow sneaking in to
the g2 square and this would be
checkmate eventually
yeah
definite no no you know
don't be tempted to swap off your light
squared bishop that protects the king i
mean i've i've seen many people get
greedy not just for a porn but for a
rook for instance they grab it and
they're like yes yes yes got my material
i'm like but look at your poor king it's
all alone
and uh unfortunately yeah you don't want
to do that
don't be greedy greedy is not good here
it's all about whether white can keep
this bishop on the board if he can he
has the advantage if he can't then black
is doing okay yeah well we should urge
all our viewers to be greedy because
there is a free ftx key up for grabs for
everyone so we're not only giving you
guys the fdx road to miami it's actually
going to be a whole summer of chess this
tournament is leading up to the big
major coming in august it's going to
take place in miami eight players will
be on site to fight it out in that major
and that's going to be the ftx crypto
cup and fdx they want to give out these
free
keys that unlock this really really cool
uh community and if you join that
community you can win amazing prices
actually up to a hundred thousand
dollars up for grabs there's going to be
exclusive content and what you do is you
scan this qr code or you go to
ftxcryptocup.com
you sign up for your free
key you become a member of this discord
community
and you can just participate in all the
action taking place both in the
tournament but also behind the scenes
with a bunch of prizes for example
i really urge you guys to uh get your
free key it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
a fun summer of chess yeah it's a great
way to just join a community support the
show you know also exchange ideas with
fellow like-minded chess players yeah
and of course like you said prizes who
wants prizes i won prizes
why these guys play chess for prizes
yeah all you have to do is sign up for
your free key and uh ftx it is one of uh
the world's uh
leading providers in um
crypto industry and uh trading
cryptocurrencies future that is well
i mean while look at the players they're
basically mimicking each other's poses
both of them with their hands on their
head or samsevian just changed his
posture there but
both of them are super determined to win
this game it's maybe more important for
levon aronian he's
around
the magical eighth spot right now i
think he's occupying that eighth spot
he needs to start winning more games and
uh samsevian just on fire this
tournament
lifting his queen up one square
attacking black's a pawn now
and uh what is levon already gonna do is
he gonna use that bishop maneuver we
mentioned is he gonna attack a few pawns
with his bishop instead
he needs to find a move he definitely
doesn't need to find a move
and uh well he's in thinking mode and
whilst he's about to take a decision
over the board
well we talked about prizes earlier we
do have a quiz of the day to celebrate
the great match between boris spassky
and bobby fisher well we're asking who
do you hold as the biggest champion in
chess history and kalengo simakoko says
that their biggest champion is magnus
coulson his brilliance exceeds chess
proving his memory iq and resilience
goes head-to-head with the estimated
bests out there with doctors engineers
lawyers teachers name them his
involvement in soccer and all knows just
shows he's an all round and uh recently
he was in las vegas playing poker as if
that's not
enough
and he's been uh
in the lead in fantasy football as well
yeah very talented magnus carlson great
mind there yeah and uh okay we do see
lavon actually
develop the light square bishop and
challenge savion's light squad
and
we also have gurav mukherjee who says
that to them the biggest champion in
chess history is the eighth world chess
champion the magician from riga mikhail
tal watching him dominate over the
sicilian defense gave glimpses of the
romantic era gold and silver coins on
the board
oh yeah he was a fabulous player you
know he really did create something
mystical over the board and you know
their sacrifices and then there were his
yeah is a fantastic choice simon's
favorite player isn't it yeah yeah i
think simon's recorded a chess ball
course on some of mikhail tells best
games yeah best attacks yeah and simon
is joining us tomorrow he will be we're
looking forward to having that but uh
meanwhile david uh
there was a really unexpected move at
least for me on the board were you
expecting the trade of bishops to happen
like that i was but not on
these terms essentially and uh we talked
about greed not being good at least on
the chessboard but samsevian he's being
extremely greedy right now will he get
punished that is the question and we
have to jump in because ivanka was
shocked by this move i wasn't expecting
it either this okay we have to uh catch
up but this bishop trade it was gonna
happen but why not just let black spend
the move exchanging your bishop instead
you trade bishops yourself and you let
the black queen even closer inching
closer now to the white king and
this spells doom
for the white king black's queen how are
you ever going to evict it as well how
are you ever going to kick it away all
it needs is a bit of backup meanwhile
sevian's idea was to go grab a pawn on
the edge of the board this pawn though
looks irrelevant and after a night trade
aronian is attacking he's pushed his
pawn forward one square now he intends
to push it even further down the board
he wants to break open this diagonal for
the black bishop if you eliminate this
board meanwhile is black's idea is
everyone's idea to lift his rook up
yeah so get across yes swinging across
in the words of simon
it's a swinger
it's a swinger it could be a winner
oh very good very good david if the rook
swings across this is just going to be
checkmate on this square how do you
defend this pawn
um okay
how how how i mean
maybe could you play bishop takes pawn
and try and protect it like this using
your bishop along this diagonal but your
king looks so weak
i did think about that i think i thought
about doing it with the queen but uh
that's a that's not
doing it with the queen's queen
yeah but it would lose it would it would
lose the bishop so
yeah uh in this position your bishop is
hanging but you are counter-attacking
against this rook
maybe the problem is that the black
bishop can drop back and oh danger on
this diagonal but look at the white king
in all of these variations the white
king is the target and no defenders
around it
let's go back to the players because in
the current position huge attack
incoming level neronian he's asking big
questions of his young rival
oh such danger on the board for sevien
um
i'm i'm
how much time does he have he doesn't
have uh that much time on the clock i
mean he has six and a half minutes
plenty of time normally but
not when i have
trouble brewing
not when you're facing one of the most
famous most fearsome attacking players
of uh his generation like iranian oh but
look at his glasses we can actually see
his screen reflecting in his glasses
that's very cool yeah there's a famous
photograph right of a chess player with
i think it's bent larsen okay
with his uh chessboard reflected in his
glasses is very very cool look oh they
actually look very much the same both
from armenia
kind of the same glasses and the same
posture right there
it's like earlier the same pose yeah
there is an armenian school of chess
actually and they have certain way of
playing which is very provocative oh so
you know they don't make too many
committal porn moves actually in fact
i'm thinking
david you could almost be an honorary
armenian and and then they just wait for
the the opponent to overextend
themselves and then
and then they come forward and get you
on a counter attack but aronian isn't
part of that score then he isn't
actually he's very very different
but
about sam then
i wouldn't say he follows that kind of
school of thought
he's a bit more aggressive sam every
time i play him i've played him a few
times over the board as well and he's
very direct he's always going for me
um i think the one time i managed to i
think we had a couple of draws but the
one time i managed to beat him over the
board it was because i used the armenian
school of chess against him i let him
push forward i basically just huddled on
my first two ranks did nothing did
nothing he came forward i grabbed a pawn
and then i curled back up into a ball
and then i think
like 80 moves later i managed to use my
extra material to win the game but
i was pretty scared the whole time it
looked like he was uh about to break
through and attack me at any moment and
that's why i think he's uncomfortable in
this position sam sevian because he
wants to be the one doing the attacking
he doesn't want to be the
attackee he doesn't want to be the one
who's finding only moves just to survive
and now okay just as expected he
couldn't tolerate that pawn any longer
so he grabbed it and he's just praying
that he can find a solution to the black
rook lifting and swinging across towards
the white king
we highlighted maybe that the white
bishop can come back to the defense i
think that's what he'll be left with i
think that's the only course of action
right now
for cevian finding a narrow path to
survival with less than five minutes on
his clock and aronian what will he do
will he just capture this pawn back with
the black rook there's an argument for
that one
or will he try this rook lift as we just
showed yeah and if the rook lift happens
the way to defend is capturing that pawn
with the bishop as you highlighted
that's the only way everything loses on
the spot
so he is walking a tightrope
and
now well levon has lots of pleasant
choices here okay so what are the
choices uh
maybe we can jump in because he is
thinking
it looks so promising this attack but
no immediate way to win
so uh the promising choice is javanka
well actually he has the possibility of
capturing the bishop
who would have thought i didn't think
about that at all
distracting the white queen away from a
nice central square yeah and after queen
takes rook now actually lifting the rook
it doesn't it's such a computer
variation this is by the way this is a
computer variation
though we mentioned that former world
champion also level erroneous some
shades of talon and some of his games um
tall would have sacrificed without
thinking simon williams ginger gm he
would have suggested this move instantly
but
yeah now suddenly look at the white
queen she's off in the no man's land off
in the middle of nowhere not able to
contribute yeah
and how does white defend this is tricky
really difficult
well white has to do the same kind of
technique you know i actually take the
pawn and uh once the rook swings over
then there are there's one check and
then i'll do this
okay so you oh my goodness mate
he's played it so this is the only way
for sevilla to defend using his queen on
this diagonal to defend the key pawn but
uh yeah let's keep an eye on the players
as we show this because he has indeed
just sacrificed his rook on the edge of
the board
sevian he hasn't reacted his only move
is to take this rook but he must be
shocked right now maybe this wasn't on
his radar either he has to take this
rook he finally does and now after the
queen is distracted
on the edge suddenly now is the time to
attack this rook is across he's swinging
across and look at the white king
completely abandoned to its own defenses
it's gonna face three attackers as well
the black queen the black rook and the
black bishop they are all going to
attack this white king this variation we
mentioned i'm just intrigued ivanka what
is going to happen here for example if
white pushes the pawn
i don't really see black's follow-up
and we're going to see this in action
we're going to see this happen white's
queen does defend the key
h2 square for now but black can just go
back and capture this pawn with a check
if the white queen swings back to defend
then black will just ignore this black
will take this pawn for example and the
black rook will swing across with a
nasty pin
this looks scary it looks scary and it's
actually happening over the board
and uh
i think the best move by the computer
actually says move the king in the
corner okay so in this position don't
jump back with the queen this is my
first instinct but actually the queen is
just a target for the black rook on the
next move and sevian of course finds the
best move um and he just hides he
shuffles into the corner the whole idea
is that after queen takes pawn with a
check he can actually block with his own
pawn i mean this looks scary anyway
suddenly black has completely conquered
the second
second rank black has picked off a whole
bunch of pawns in the process but at
least white is defending this guy with
his queen from afar at least white now
has some time to maybe bring his rook
into the defense
it's hanging by a thread though for
sevian it totally is absolutely
petrifying and i just love the computer
evaluation
zero
zero zero you don't care
i'm just like look at the position it is
wild it is crazy and this is why you
shouldn't just kind of like judge a
computer position by the computer
evaluation because there is equal
positions but there's also terrifyingly
equal possessions where someone is
walking a tightrope someone is having to
tread very very carefully it's great at
noticing the blunders the bar it always
reacts big time when we do have the
blunders i've noticed that it uh
it
it never favors your move so it only
goes sort of down after you can never
make a genius move according to the
computer it only goes up for you when
your opponent makes a bad move kind of
yeah it's it's like a parent you can
never impress it but you can always
disappoint
you can never do right in the eyes of
the computer
although did we kind of see it in the
game between jew and jun and richard
report
when you made some really really nice
moves in the end sometimes if you're
really quick if you spot something
really fast then the computer might need
two or three seconds but if you get
there first then you can
so that's the trick then you can look at
her play great moves really really fast
that's the only way to impress the
computer
it's not easy to do unfortunately
unfortunately for us but uh meanwhile
the position has followed the variation
we showed on the board white's rook now
swinging across to attack this black
queen
and the black queen has to run will she
go and grab another pawn she does so
right now the material count if we do a
bit of maths here white has a rook in
return black has a bishop and a pawn
i say ander pawn because i did a quick
count but yes black does have one pawn
more than white right now so
white is technically a little bit of
material ahead but it's all about the
white king white's king is far more
vulnerable than his counterpart black's
king has enough pawn shelter around it
to feel comfortable
and
yeah how is sevillan going to release
this tension the problem here
is that although the position might be
equal
how do you maintain the equality you
can't force a draw anytime soon
especially with queens on the board
if you can't force the queens off how do
you protect your king the white king
long term
i don't really see it okay he gives a
check first of all
forcing the black king to the side of
the board most likely but how about the
white rooks are they not sort of
protecting the white king they are
they are just standing there covering
some squares i was going to say they're
not at all protecting the working
they're not protecting the key second
rank no that's that's true but they kind
of are taking some squares away from the
attackers so basically you don't want
your works on the same line as the king
you want them to yeah
to stop the sort of the line where yeah
the opening pieces wants to come i mean
for example the ideal setup the
defensive set up for white one would
maybe protect the same line as the king
one would protect the line in front of
it so at the moment the two white rooks
they're doing the exact same job as each
other so one rook is basically useless
it's like hiring two people to do the
same job uh these two white rooks
yeah one of them wants to be on a better
square but one of them is kind of stuck
next to his uh his colleague there so
um
i'm not 100 sure what irony is
considering here there's only two legal
moves you either move the black king to
the edge of the board or you move the
black bishop back to block this check
from the white queen retreating the
black bishop looks counter-intuitive and
looks wrong
the black bishop's on such a nice square
but i guess he wants to stop something
very specific
um he wants to stop any further checks
so
interesting decision there by uh sevian
giving this check with the white queen
and yeah that's an interesting question
can the white rooks improve themselves
and actually just to show this point
that you bring up their kaya um right
now the two white rooks especially this
one i'm thinking um this rook
it's just staring at its own pawn it's
not really doing too much apart from
covering the first rank so this is the
kind of
the problem piece but uh if black now
runs away from this check and lifts his
king to the side of the board sevian's
plan is to drop back give another check
and if this check is blocked now he
wants to kind of set up this perfect
defensive scenario he wants to lift his
rook up one square protected by the
queen so the queen guards the third rank
the rook guards the second rank and this
rook guards the first rank
and together these three pieces they
kind of cover all the holes at least
going across the board uh so now for
example this rook kicks away the black
queen the queen has to retreat far away
and also it protects this vulnerable
square so that's why
levon aronian after this queen check
decided he didn't want to put his king
on the edge of the board where it would
get checked again uh he didn't want to
allow this time gaining check for the
white queen so he retreated so he
retreated his bishop but this bishop is
now pinned it's out of the attack and
sevian decides okay he's going to go
back with his queen and guard this
square
only now does level neroni and this is
flashy only now does he put his king on
the edge of the board he's saying okay
now there's no more checks with your
queen the king is safe here and of
course a trap this bishop is poisoned it
can't be captured because the queen
would lose protection
of the port in front of the king this
would be checkmate
so right now
uh this bishop cannot be captured how
does sevian improve his rooks
big big question
yeah maybe one that he can't answer
actually for the time being he has to
just bring his queen
queen back
and uh again threaten some checks yep to
this square or the square maybe uh maybe
this guy's more accurate just so you
throw in some checks
and okay meanwhile he's started to
harass the black queen he really wants
to kick the black queen off the second
rank uh this is the target of course
it's defended right now but he just
wants to kick away the black queen maybe
we'll see a bit of a dance here the
black queen moves the white rook attacks
it the black queen moves the white rook
attacks it uh the white the black queen
moves the white rook continues to attack
it there's nowhere for this queen to
hide where it can't get attacked uh and
hit by the white rook
that's actually very clever by uh
samsevian here in the current position
how does this black queen hide from the
white rook
you can't hide anywhere on the second
rank anymore and uh you want to stay on
the second rank to attack this port yeah
um
there's nothing for it i mean the only
option i can see is that
nope i mean if you go back then at least
you're on a bad square now and white
could even get greedy exactly you take
the bishop
and
suddenly white's rooks they're primed to
defend so no i think you have to
maintain that connection with the pawn
on h2
so do this dance move the queen attack
move the queen attack move the green
attack etc and then we go back the other
way we dance right then we dance left
and the game will end in a repetition of
moves it looks like
maybe the players have justified the
computer evaluation of 0.0 after all ah
yeah they've turned a wild position into
a draw one yeah and
well you know they do say chess is a
draw it's just both players playing
great chess yeah that's it and
it took me a long time to accept that
this can happen but a game
doesn't matter who you're playing
against can just play
just end perfectly with the draw both
players played exceptionally well the
end
i always thought that you know somewhere
other you had to you know win everything
and it wasn't until i started working
with a serbian grandmaster that he kind
of helped me see that no it's okay
sometimes a draw is a fair result and uh
talking about
wanting to win
levon iranian says no i do not want to
be involved in this dance i do not want
to do that tango and instead steps back
the queen to the third row protecting
the bishop
but
this is not an aggressive move at all
this is just passive computer does not
like it computer hates it and that's
because black has completely gone away
from his pressure on the second rank we
mentioned that having that pressure on
the second rank was the only thing that
kept black's attack alive
and now black's queen is no longer
threatening the pawn in front of the
white king so sam's heavy and sevian can
get greedy with the white queen and he's
gone to grab a pawn
right now he's a rook for bishop up
that's a significant advantage that will
be decisive in any end game
so uh yeah what is love on iranian's
justification
i don't see it
is he planning to maybe just i was going
to say use the bishop now as an attacker
and okay the question is how is white
going to think about defending that pawn
first of all he has a few checks but
that's probably not a good idea to throw
them in
we also mentioned that using the white
rooks on the second rank is the ideal
defensive setup maybe one of the white
rooks i'm not sure which one but one of
the white rooks could step up to the
second rank defend across the board
again
and
there we go yep defending the pawn in
front of the white king that's the key
target that's the only target actually
in white's position right now and
i think level iranian he just played a
one move trick basically and it's been
thwarted it's been stopped
and
i don't see it white's queen can come
back to the center and give check
anytime as you mentioned white's queen
is also attacking one of the black pawns
on the f7 square
what's the follow-up what has levon
ironian got in store for us
if he doesn't find anything now he's
just gonna lose
and capturing that pawn is a big threat
as well so
yeah he could have forced a draw instead
he's gambling with his future in this
game
fortune favors the brave they say but
this is
maybe a bit too brave i think this is a
product of uh his tournament situation
you know he's been struggling a little
bit yesterday was a bad day and
we saw that when humans are playing
chess psychological issues are at stake
and often people tend to take dubious
you know
uh gambles and and risks
i mean we saw it in the world
championship match as well with um new
pomniacci you know first of all he
spurned draw when magnus offered it and
then he decided to play really
aggressively and uh here we kind of have
the same situation yeah he had a chance
for a draw and instead he's
gone for the option of
suffering for the draw
if if that's going to happen
yeah rooney and suddenly he's been
thinking for a minute and a half now i
think he's suddenly realizing that just
one rush of blood to the head and
he's got to fight for this uh result all
over again he's back to square one he's
material down as well which isn't ideal
and okay this is a step in the wrong
direction moving the rook away from the
white king
protecting a porn yes
maybe he can protect this rook uh
next move and he's got a nice setup
defensive set up there but that's the
key word defensive he's uh shaking his
head a moment ago level running
i think it's a miracle if he holds this
game now oh he's really struggling
against the youngsters he lost yesterday
to arjun nergaisi he lost a game earlier
today against jeffrey chong
and maybe also samuel savion will win
his game against
the top rated player in the tournament
the oldest player in the tournament as
well the honorarian yeah
and sevien
i hope this is a nice move offering a
trade of queens and at the same time
yeah
you're gonna say at the same time
because i suddenly dawned on me like you
say when you say forcing the queen i was
like there's no other option it's game
over i think it might well be game over
and level neronian he's about to go down
to another defeat because look at what's
about to happen this last move this
really really sneaky move by sam cevian
putting his queen on this square not
only is he offering the queen trade but
as yovanka mentioned he's pinned this
black rook to the black king so if black
wants to avoid a queen trade which would
be terminal
then where do you put the black queen no
matter where you put it for example if
you swing it across white's rook is just
going to lift up the board and can you
prevent the queen trade anymore are you
just about to lose material it looks
that way
maybe you could make an argument for
throwing the bishop in the way but
you're just walking into a pin on this
rank you're walking into a pin on this
diagonal it just looks terrible for
black and
yeah i mean i just don't see any other
way in this current position no matter
where you put the queen if you put it on
this side of the board the white rook
still comes up hitting the black queen
hitting the black rook and remember the
black rook is completely paralyzed along
this diagonal white will win material
and uh that's the question if the queens
do come off then after queen takes queen
for example the reason this is so
hopeless even if you win a porn is black
is because white has this guy white has
a passport
and this board is simply going to run up
the board supported by actually one of
the rooks behind and next move push push
push you'll make a new queen and win the
game it's that simple at this moment so
if the queens disappear it is
100 hopeless for black level neroni
needs a trick he needs to keep the
queens on the board but
it might come at material loss wow it's
looking great for sam sevion and uh
jeffrey chong he was on top of the table
before this round he has just lost his
game to richard report and with a win in
this game sam seville will take the sole
lead in the ftx road to miami
preliminary super impressive by the 21
year old and look at that another win
for juwan jun she just won her game
against uh sam shanklin you're like how
well impressed and happy are you to see
jew
i'm ecstatic to see drew when jun do so
well you know she is a great player and
she is really an inspiration to our quiz
of the day is asking about champions
june june is one of them yeah and uh i
i'm so i'm so pretty proud for her
because
we've actually often seen the women come
on and they've struggled a little bit
but here she just seems to be in her
elements she's getting better and better
three wins in a row she's in contention
for a qualification
knockout station would be the first to
see her do that that would be amazing
we're going to keep close eye on jew
engine she's playing some fantastic
chess but so is sam savion david you're
saying he is about to win this game i
think so um this last rook move it
wasn't the one that i was maybe
expecting but this still puts pressure
on the black queen and maybe forces the
black queen to an even worse square
remember she has to defend her rook and
that's not easy in the first place i
think a queen exchange is imminent and
if that ever happens it will be a white
win
so uh sevian he can just bully aronian
constantly due to the pin along that
diagonal due to any queen trades you can
just say okay i'm offering a queen trade
you retreat i'm gonna offer another
queen trade you go to an even worse
square eventually something will give
and uh aronian we nearly never see him
in this situation one minute on the
clock for aronian i can't remember the
last time i saw him in such bad time
trouble
no uh
he's not gonna say quick as well he's so
quick yeah and okay well now he's uh
struggling over the board
the queen has to move to defend the rook
and uh you can just see it on his face
he's not happy he's shaking his head and
it will be running through his mind as
well that you know he should have just
accepted the draw when it was offered to
him on a plate why did he do this to
himself it was totally self-inflicted
but
we do this in chess
and we do love the fighting spirits yeah
yes fighting chess index will uh improve
due to this game but he will regret that
it was only five moves ago he could have
pretty much forced to draw
five moves later just suffering and down
to 15 seconds on the clock ironian
hopeless position
i'm surprised the computer only says
plus 2.5 for white yeah look at this the
queen's sam savian has forced them off
the board all he needs to do now take
this one back with your pawn swing the
white rook across support the white a
pawn and start motoring it up the board
yeah it's just
inevitable now it might take a while if
black for example uses the rook to go
and blockade white's past a porn as he
does but it is inevitable white's other
rook will kick away the black rook at
any moment white's king can join the fun
matter of time it is totally a matter of
time and uh also it's not that difficult
for serbian to do this because he just
has to keep pushing forward with his
pawns and he has
two rooks
basically and the bricks are better than
the bishop and as david says you've got
to remember that uh in-game maxim
teamwork makes the dream work so don't
forget to use your king as well
use every single piece and the goal
push forward with the pawn
two rooks are better than one that's uh
the motto here black's bishop as well
just hits thin air it's got no stable
squares
and it's all about this board alice the
a pawn is going to win the game yeah
and uh yeah i think level neronian
he's just playing
out of inertia right now he knows that
he's about to lose but it's hard to just
admit defeat maybe he'll try to set one
final trap somehow i don't ever see that
happening to be honest but look at this
the white rooks are just gonna kick away
the black pieces
and uh well if samsung wins this game
it's looking great for him right now
he's uh guaranteed to be on top of the
table heading into day three because he
was supposed to face team rajab in the
final round today but that will be a
walk-over win for samuel savion what a
day
if he wins plus the walk-over win that's
five in a row i think for sam
wow that must be close to a record in
the tour yeah it might well be
and he won another one yesterday as well
so i think he'll have what after this
assuming he wins this game it will be
six wins no defeats
from the first two days
that's uh that's a mighty score it's a
very impressive score
and uh suddenly it is the e pawn that
has uh marched its way and the goal is
very simple that rook that black has it
needs to move it's going to be
challenged any time now and
levon yeah he's just playing because he
can't bring himself to resign
yeah he just moves his king across
white's king is going to step into the
center
fights rook first as siobhan mentions is
going to kick away the black rook and
this pattern is going to continue
black's rook eventually will have to
step back
it gets kicked away okay now it's trying
to activate but uh
savian says no checks for you the white
the white rook is just gonna swing
across to the b file and go up to the
seventh rank and that will be game over
white's king also has a clear path
towards the black rook
nothing to do yeah
yeah just stopping black's pawns from
advancing it's all very nice technique
from the young american
and
this is where you think why do pawns
have to make
turn into queens when they get promoted
all the way to the end of the board
why why are the rules of tests like that
why can't they just stay pawns and just
i don't know what they can do
but anyway
the white rook is threatening to come
okay so levon is trying to create some
kind of
counter play but savion is saying no
that's it the white king is coming
forward
and
again the king can set forward or to the
d5 square the white rook can also move
to b3 and again get on to the golden
seventh row
just has nothing to do nothing to do
15 seconds on the clock yeah
yep hopeless
not much else to say unfortunately yeah
definitely tough tough position for the
i mean he gives a check
and uh
maybe it's time for seven to get tempted
and switch taxes because uh the black
king is there on the edge of the board
so it might be tempting just to put the
king on f5
and go for checkmates instead
yep that would be a very uh fancy way
[Laughter]
okay
he is just fidgeting he is not
comfortable he knows he's losing this
game i guess another loss against a
youngster a bunch of the other games
have finished a win for a niche geary
against uh radis lavoitacek all right so
it's looking better for anish geary
today he really struggled yesterday but
the dutch man is back and duda also
winning his game against hans niemann
richard report won his game against
jeffrey chung that means samuel savion
will overtake first place and as
mentioned ju when wenjun winning another
game
and this one against sam shanklin who is
uh struggling a lot sam shanklin he is
one of the top-rated american guys he is
ready to play in the olympiad for the us
team but uh struggling in this
tournament
he's also one of the this is sam one of
the most well prepared guys and uh he's
the author of several chessboard courses
which are amazing i have to say
and uh
yeah so it's kind of
it's kind of surprising to see him not
do so well yeah but having said that
he's also one of the few grandmasters
who's very honest about how he feels the
pressure when he's playing tournaments
that you know he enjoys studying a lot
but it's something completely different
when he's sat there and he has to make
those moves himself yeah
he's very emotional and that i think
that comes with pros and cons it means
you can be a very form player if you're
feeling happy
uh when sam's on form he's on fire he
tends to go on winning streaks
but uh yeah when things aren't going so
well that can affect you
and that seems to be the case so far for
shankland
meanwhile there was a big threat on the
board white rook was going to swing
across deliver checkmate
levon iranian has prevented that the
black king now has one escape square but
i don't think this is going to be a
permanent solution unfortunately after a
porn trade now
i think white is still coasting to
victory in this game white's pawn as
well the a pawn can step forward any
moment and black's bishop will have to
give itself up
for that white pawn so the evaluation
bar now ever increasing up to nearly
plus eight for white
that means white is about to go even
further up on material and win this game
and pawn takes pawn played
king takes pawn the only move
nothing to be done apart from that the
king could slide across one square maybe
but uh yeah it doesn't change the
evaluation of the position this move
will cost black his bishop and levon
iranian is gambling all of his hopes on
the black h-pawn the problem is white
has two rooks with which to stop it
and uh
one of the white rooks will at some
point swing across
simply nothing to do and i think we
there have a result samsevian wins a
really impressive game